hello welcome to spend less time
diagnosing and more time developing I'm
Eric macclenny a software engineer at
Google on developer infrastructure and
I'm sure a trough I'm a product manager
working on developer infrastructure and
our goal is to make developers lives
easier I know you're all here to learn
about the various tools and diagnostic
tools that we're about to show you but
first we should probably talk about the
app right yeah so the app that we have
built is basically a meme generator you
can take any two bodies of text and
throw it at this app this app will the
this app will basically take randomly
will pick words from this bodies of text
kind of mush them together in some
logical manner to hopefully sometimes
create a funny meme so in this for this
demo we decided to take the two bodies
of text that we decided to use is
Grimm's fairy tales and of course
everyone's favorite bedtime reading the
gates handbook so let's walk through
what happens when you try this app out
like here's a good example it says the
wolf and the wild boar were first on the
ground and when they came he gave them
some of the most annoying problems known
to humanity version controlling and
Microsoft Word documents and that's
that's pretty it's pretty rough I don't
know if that's the most annoying problem
maybe one of them so you want to just
walk them through and Robert works what
we're doing is we're taking fragments
from each of the source sentences and
you can see if you kind of have a little
fancy font for the for the Grimm's fairy
tales and we have kind of a nice
monospaced font for the get handbook and
for each of the source fragments we've
highlighted them in the source sentence
and then we've kind of chain them
together as you
see here yeah and you know sometimes you
can see it's taken about eight sentences
to make this we have taken words across
randomly across eight different
sentences assemble all of this this is
all happening in a state machine that's
running on App Engine and I've seen this
app sometimes take 12 13 sentences
sometimes as few as three sentences you
can start sometimes in gates handbook
and go to Grimm's and sometimes you can
start from Grimm's to get some Grimm's
and so on any combination you know let's
keep this another example and tell you
how the app itself is built it's a very
straightforward very simple very simple
that you're too two bodies of text that
i was talking about it exists in GCS in
two different stores we have a runtime
it's it's basically a java app which has
the state machine and of course the
green box indicates the client you know
why don't we just show them the app
that's a good idea here's the app
running as you can see i have another
sentence here he went to the fireplace
to make a comment on it github notices
that and collapses the outdated diff
it's the mayor I guess is that funny I
don't know there's another feature we
haven't talked about which is our voting
feature so we can we can click one of
these buttons down here and it will it
will record our response and then
generate another sentence I don't know I
think it's a little funny so we'll click
that one and did you click on it I did
it's sitting it's loading here wow
that's that's the key in a really long
time you don't expect us to ship this
app to you ah wait that that it's a demo
app certified never gonna ship it but I
mean if we were to ship this I think we
want to investigate this this little
performance problem here yeah so what do
you think we're going to use well a good
option to use for these kinds of things
as logs logs are very very flexible you
can record any information that we want
in the case of App Engine they tell us
how long our requests take we could
start there use trays maybe we also have
a trace product
and it's convenient cuz I happen to have
worked on this product hours it's
designed to show us links the
information for our apps and kind of
give us a view into the service our pcs
that are apps call so what while you're
putting up the app why don't I just
could you just go back to the slides I
can just talk about about so when when
we talk about when we think about
performance troubleshooting in
production we've heard engineers tell
that of course you need to be able to
very accurately and very precisely
measure requests measure latency at an
individual request level you also need
to be able to correlate logs so that you
actually get this end-to-end view of
what's happening within your application
from a latency point of view and you
need to be able to look at different
distribution slices and what I mean by
that is average itself doesn't tell you
much you need to be able to look at the
75th percentile on what I mean you made
when you look at an average view an
average aggregate view of your entire of
the latency associated with your
application you may not notice any
issues but if you slice it down to the
75th percentile or the 95th percentile
you'll start seeing you start seeing
those those differences in layton season
that becomes that becomes a place where
you want to start diving into and the
other thing that we have heard customers
often say is performance is something
that people end up engineers end up
reacting to while they would much rather
prefer being proactive about this to
know before to be able to be aware of
the problems even before it actually
impacts the customers so with all that
in mind we we ended up building
stackdriver trays and for stackdriver
trays we we started off with of course
providing this very we are we
automatically trace every endpoint that
you have and we were able to surface
that within within these stacked I would
praise too we also overlay this logs so
we can
basically this diagram what you see here
is basically we tell you what's
happening across your the entire time
taken for your entire request and then
we also break it down into its
constituent parts and tell you where
exactly the time is being spent we are
able to also break down by different
distribution slices so you can actually
tell for example what is what is your
application latency at the 25th
percentile at the 75th of the 50th
percentile and we're also able to tell
you whether it's actually going up or
down Eric will show you some of these in
a second and we have spent a bunch of
time looking at a being able to provide
analysis on all of these and Eric I
think we should just actually just show
them the tool all right maybe you could
drive here why yeah actually why don't I
do that here we have our tres overview
page and the page is organized in a
number of cards that are designed to
give different views into the tracia
that we have for the app on the upper
right side we have our insights card and
this shows some of the insights that she
watches talked about and we'll look at
this in more detail we see one that's
called mini data store next calls maybe
that will come up later in our
conversation and then below that we have
a few lists of traces that are organized
different ways the first one the traces
are organized by frequent bye-bye
recency and then below that we have
traces organized both by frequency of
request URL and by frequency of App
Engine service RPC on the right side we
have our list of analysis reports this
is what we're showing just a moment ago
in the slides the analysis reports are
capable of running over large numbers of
traces and
they can show you a latency histogram
for your app for the requested it
handles and what we do on the daily
reports these ones are generated
automatically and we if we have enough
data if we have enough data we can show
to reports in this case for the daily
reports we have the first day which is
yesterday and then we have a week before
yesterday and we're kind of showing you
those two reports side by side so this
can show you if you have a latency shift
perhaps in your app it's it's probably
also worth noting that it's these
reports this comparison between reports
may not be just done at a on a time time
basis you can do it on a version to
version basis so we can generate reports
saying tell me my application profile
for my and compare it with what it was
with with my previous version that's
right and for the daily reports the ones
that are automatically generated me
choose from requests that were sent to
the most frequent you our eyes that's
another way place that we use that
information all right well when we try
to generate our sentence that took a
little longer than we thought it should
so now we're going to look at a trace
detail for the sentence so we can see
here we've got some long-running
requests here for sentence that one took
almost 19 seconds we're going to look at
the trace detail page for this gonna
click on that I yes you should okay that
should we start using trace from our
maybe we should use traces I use our own
featured on our service said what you
say I'm not saying that you're saying
that but a good idea but actually we I
there's something going on here and
we'll talk about that too oh it's a disc
trying to retrieve a whole bunch of data
is trying to retrieve a lot of data so
here we see our trace now a trace is a
bucket basically a group of spans and
the spins have some basic information
they have a name and then we get the
latency information by the timing that
you have in the stands there's both the
start time
and an end time so we can organize thins
kind of in space and we also have the
latency for them and they also have a
hierarchy so the request here the entire
request duration you see in the first
band called / sentence and then all the
ones below about our children of that
parents pin so it gives us a
hierarchical representation of what our
app is doing it's a huge number of these
there is a large number of those and I
think probably it the page load was
because we're actually loading probably
thousands of these things and showing
them here in our browser okay so in fact
there's so many I mean you barely see
the little scroll from moving I can't
even count you so why don't we click on
the summary tab there okay now in the
summary tab it shows us by request and
service RPC just how many of these spans
that we see this case we see over 2,000
datastore next calls below that we see
that we have eight run query calls and I
think with this information I have kind
of an idea of what our app is doing and
let me just go back to the grim get app
here for just a second mute me to show
up i'm just going to explain what it's
doing what it does to generate that list
of source sentences is the about a large
state machine with all the different
sentence fragments in it and we just
kind of walk about to generate the
generated sentence but to come up with
the source sentences for each source
that was chosen for the node for that
sentence fragment we hash the sentence
and we store that hash in the node we do
this because we have a lot of sentences
and a lot of nodes and when I just kind
of replicate all the sentences
everywhere and then we look into our
data store by hash to find each of the
source sentences so in this case we had
a sentence that had eight source
sentences and we did eight queries but
for some reason that turned into over
2000 datastore next calls this is one of
the benefits of trace it kind of gives
us this few if you look at the code we
don't actually see ourselves ever
calling data store next what we're gonna
we're going to use trace to figure out
why that's happening yeah now we click
on the insights tab and you can see it's
telling us there's one in sight on the
tab we click on it and actually you see
the insight that we saw on the inside
card
it says many data stored next calls and
it's warning us that not only do we have
a lot of these calls and it has the
correct number but it's telling us that
we have a default maybe have a batch
size for our curry of 20 and I know that
20 is the default batch size and this is
probably why we have so many of these
next calls now one thing that I think is
notable is in this case we kind of
diagnose our problem we started at the
ovary page we clicked on the actual
summary the sentence link from our list
of traces we went to the detail page we
looked up the summary to see how many of
these calls he made we ended up in sight
we could have just clicked on insights
from that overview page and kind of skip
some of the investigation so this is
kind of one of the values of our
insights feature the other thing to
remember is what we are showing here is
just one such pattern we are analyzing
every single trace that comes into our
system every one of them we analyzed for
numerous patterns when we see a
suboptimal pattern in your call flow we
immediately surface that are so you have
this insights available to you the
moment you land on the trace page and
we're working on new insights all the
time we're always working on new news
right yeah so now we're going to go back
to our timeline here and we're going to
try to we're going to go to that section
of code that has that problem so to do
this we're going to click on the one of
the first run query there okay now i
mentioned that each spin has some basic
information it's got a name it's got
some timing information if you scroll
down we also see we have some of what we
call annotations or labels these can be
used to actually add extra custom data
to the spins and for app engine spins we
add a number of different things based
on the service api we call so you can
see for data store we have kind of like
the batch size and there in fact it says
20 right there we have you know the kind
which is roughly corresponds to the
table that the data came from for that
request below that we also have a call
stack
and this is going to help us kind of
find a place in code where we have our
bug or performance problem you can see
in our call stack we have many friends
there frames that are kind of part of
the SDK the App Engine SDK we have some
App Engine infrastructure or some
servlet container code but we have some
links here for the frames that
correspond to our appt deep they just
ship this you're going a little bit off
script you realize that I know I
actually shifted in the last 20 minutes
i think or last half an hour i know i
was hoping that nobody would modify this
while we're doing the demo but here we
click on it these things happen let's
click on that which one to pick on the
first one all right it should take it to
the debugger yeah yeah well and well
there's a little sneak peek of sorry
other teeth on a team is just shipping
stuff as we are demoing here so we
didn't expect to see this link those
links were not supposed to be there well
actually are supposed to be here just
not today not right now but nevertheless
okay so here we have our debugger and we
have source code located we've uploaded
our source code here into the Google
Cloud source repository that's what we
have that available on and we're just
going to talk about this debugger in a
few minutes but what this is doing is
it's letting me take a look at the code
that I have for my fine sentence method
this is the method that goes through the
data store as I mentioned it kind of
looks for sentences with a matching hash
and let's look at what it does it first
steps up a query and then it goes
through all the entities it gets from
the iterator front from that iterable
there and for each entity it looks at
the value property the value property is
the source sentence itself and then we
hash the sentence and then we compare
the hashes for equality the hash that
you pass into the method is the one that
we got out of our state machine and it's
curious to me because I remember working
on this and I know that when I write the
entities into the datastore I actually
write a hash property there so right
away you can see we're computing a hash
for the sentence from the datastore but
that's not the only thing by adding the
hash property by default the datastore
gives us the secondary index
that property so i can actually apply a
filter to my query and you would look up
what this is doing by iterating through
the table this way we're actually
potentially iterating over all the
entities in the table for this kind and
we kind of know the hash are ready for
what we're looking for us if you should
be able to just do a lookup now as I
mentioned by default you don't see
anything here about batch size the
default batch size is 20 and what the
kind of sdk code is doing is its is it's
saying all right we're going to query
this table for these entities and it's
kind of fetching ahead the batch size
number of entities and it's kind of
holding those there as we iterate
through them and when we exhaust that it
goes and gets the next batch so you got
to have some default batch size and 20
is probably good for some common use
cases like maybe a web page or the
tabular view yeah right in this case we
know that we're iterating through the
entire table so 20 is probably too small
given that we have thousands of
sentences in this table so what I'm
going to do is replace where we call
this with a call to another method that
applies a filter and having planned
ahead i actually have such a method down
below maybe you can scroll down a little
bit past all these two to go don't be
shy keep going all right right there
find sentence with filter this one adds
a filter to our query and and as a
predicate with an equality operator so
we're looking for entities with the
property hash that equals the hash that
we pass in and they should translate
into a data store look up instead of a
scan you won't be scanning through the
whole table chunks of 20 sentences at a
time here we'll go straight to our
straight to our sentence should we try
it out or why don't we try this out yeah
so the the unscripted part here as folks
realized we clicked on a feature that
probably just got enabled some point
today you have the ability to jump from
stackdriver trays into debugger we'll
talk a little bit about we'll talk a
little more about debugger
in just a few minutes in the meantime
okay so I'm going to built them I'm
building and deploying this thing and
I'm going to just go and change it back
to the slide so you can yeah why don't
we go back to the slides and I can talk
a little bit with the clicker so the
thing to remember about traces it's
always on its all it's ready it's
available out of the box for all App
Engine applications we do all the
joining and aggregation in the back end
all the reports that you see we generate
a lot of them automatically and you can
if you want to generate more and you
want to have generate your own custom
reports for a specific endpoint or over
a specific time period specific version
you can do all of that we are checking
for regression all the time in the sense
that we are checking for latency
regressions or performance regressions
across from one version to another or
over time and we surface that up we
surface that to you as well and the
recurring team you'll see this in the
remaining tools there's miniscule
overhead there's very little overhead
for your application think in terms of
single-digit milliseconds or lesser in
the order of microseconds that we do
when we do sample when we do sample a
request and take a trace for know how
I'll just quickly go through how trace
works at a very high level there is what
we have here in that box is yeah right
there well this is basically the app
that we are talking about it sits on top
of the App Engine platform and what
trace does is it hooks into the request
handling there so that every time you
may do a URL fetch at an RPC we are able
to do this start and stop and we send it
out a lot send it from where it gets
shipped to our trace service gets
shipped back to a back-end store we had
blue some MapReduce and and Eric and his
team does some magic there and we have
this analysis and report that we just
talked about we also have
Tracy API that you can use to extend it
so that if you have your own internal
workflows as an example that you want to
trace and you want over late and the
trace data and you want to leverage all
the goodness that we we talked about you
can use it by using the API and an SDK
that we have out there we also have the
ability to use the same api's to build
to show trace data into your own tools
so are we ready to go try this out here
we are right
so here we have another sentence that we
generated last time and I can't I didn't
I don't even know how to read that read
me 12 + + 1 point yeah this doesn't know
maybe this isn't that funny well looks
like that with make sense you can see
we've greatly improved the performance
of our app here it's not as much better
or faster in fact if we were to look
here at the trace look at it trace list
here you can see here this / sentence
took two hundred twenty milliseconds now
this is you can see what I was talking
about before down here it says we have
force or sentences actually this must
not correspond to the same one but we
have just a number of run query calls
here and we have no data store next
calls so we've we've visit the reason
why our app is so much faster this looks
much better i mean the app is djibouti
why don't you get the world i mean i
think right now we are probably ready to
try out a different set of source text
data that's this is really good eating
great what is it whoa that's a lot of
tread there 500 internal server error if
I the channel my inner Yoda to you know
you know introduced a bug you have weed
this looks like a pretty bad bug it
maybe not as bad as the joke but uh no
I'm scared that's it that was your Yoda
a little more work you're Yoda is gonna
be this top light so so what are we
going to do we're going to well you know
like i said before logs is kind of a
theme that we have here logs were great
tools are very flexible we can probably
find the place in code where this is
happening and we can look and see if
there's anything in there may be an
exception in there something that's like
going through i don't know like you know
tons and tons of logs probably a lot of
lux stackdriver at a reporting yes
that's that's right here we'll talk
about error pudding right so let's
let's talk about error reporting so as
Eric was describing I mean we could
certainly go look at logs you've got
errors scattered everywhere all over
logs and it's really difficult to get
this over all of you it's also difficult
to evaluate the impact of just looking
at errors within the logs so great if
you do find an error in log what do you
do do do you basically stop everything
and start trying to fix it or I mean how
what is the best way to gauge when you
encounter errors in the log is it's
always been a difficult thing
discovering new issues takes a long time
very often you get to know about issues
only after after your customers have
already seen it and start complaining
and it's difficult to validate often
whether the fixes that you are made in
the version that you're aboard a ship
out is actually saw the error or not and
I mean if anyone is I'm sure everyone
here has probably looked at error log
statements and it's just so much noise
in there there is so much stuff in there
irrelevant very often irrelevant stuff
that you know it is my eyes tend to
glaze over so what we did is this
morning we launched publicly stack
driver error reporting if there's one
takeaway I want everyone to have here is
this if there's a page that you want to
pin to your favorites it's probably
error reporting I'll just walk through
the various parts really quickly and
then we can just start looking at the
tool itself there's a lot of information
and we tried our goal is to give you a
one it's it's a it's at a glance view of
all the errors happening within your
application we go about taking all the
errors that you that encounter across
all the instances across all the law
across logs across all instances and we
group them intelligently so that you
don't have to worry about how often it's
it's occurring we allow you to slice it
by different time periods we can you can
slice it by different versions we
have an easy way to show that a new
error has occurred a very use an
intuitive way to immediately spot when a
new error has occurred we try to tell
you when available the customer impact
how many customers are being impacted we
you can sign up for notifications and
you can link it to your own bug tracking
system so all of this goes that there is
tremendous amount of information here
but I think why don't we just actually
see the seed in action oh actually
before we do that at me to see this in
action first so this is again a very
high level view of how error reporting
works we ingest a ton of logs there's a
big black box or blue box in this case
which does a bunch of processing and
grouping and we basically group output
of that is the scintillating grouping
that we'll we'll see in action and in a
few minutes that of course goes to a
service which allows us to do a bunch of
things and as well as as well as surface
this tu tu ru I using an API and that
API just like a trace is available for
you to ingest into your own third-party
tools and of course we have a notifier
that sends you notifications when
there's a new error tree look at the two
yeah let's do that
and one thing I want to mention all
these can be found here on the left down
here where it's this back driver you've
got debug which we showed you briefly as
I going to go about trace and error
reporting what you're talking about
today logging which we're not bashing
logging is great but I'm going to keep
bringing this up and we've got
monitoring under the stock driver
section there and you can also pin these
things exactly that's that what you're
going to say that's about as you
practice this this is why we're but on
the top I've got my error reporting I
come so I'm going to click that one and
here we have our overview page and we
showed you this briefly before and here
we have our errors that are kind of
organized by kind and off to the right
we have one that happened three minutes
ago and I think this just going to go on
a limb and say this is probably one that
we want to click this probably is what
we saw before it's also telling us that
kind of the status that's seeing for
these is 500 which matches the big sea
of red that we saw before so we're going
to click this and we're looking at the
error details at the top of the page
here the top table that we've got we see
some of the same information that you
saw in the overview page the corresponds
to this error you have a kind of a
blown-up histogram as you go through
this you'll see if we can see that we've
had over time for this error type and
then for each type of error we have a
number of samples and for each sample we
have some additional information and
this kind of is information about the
request or the environment that the app
is running in and this is designed to
help us reproduce this problem we can
see we've got the full request URL
you've got the status which we saw
firsthand then we've got some headers we
got the user agent to refer and App
Engine informations default is the app
engine module and then we have the
version that the app was running and
this request now below this we have a
stack trace but this deck trace looks
different from the one that we saw in
cloud dress it's dr. betrays why is that
it's cleaner I mean is cleaner it's much
better if it to my eyes well if i expand
this you'll see what's happened here as
i said before in our stack trace we have
many frames a lot of them are kind of
infrastructure it doesn't mean that the
bug we're seeing doesn't happen there
but it's probably more likely that it's
happening in our application code for
just be honest with ourselves so here
we've kind of formatted this and we've
greyed out the kind of infrastructure or
frames and then we just show it with the
ability to kind of collapse it so that
we just see our frames from our house so
this is very useful and helping us kind
of just visually see where our errors
are happening that's exactly what i was
talking about where if you just show the
draw information there i mean it's
difficult to discern and i think that's
really cool that you can actually zero
in on exactly where the problematic yeah
and now looking at this I think I have
an idea of where this where this bug is
is happening oh yeah read of it you got
all apparently it's on markov surly that
class method called do you get line 122
so I mean how how are you going to
confirm that well one option will be to
use logs I said I was going to say this
again and of course we could go in there
and we can we can instrument our code
some more we can try to guess it what
this is a null pointer exception so we
can see if we're dereferencing something
that looks like it might be no we can
print the logs out we can build we can
redeploy we can hit the app again I mean
that's involves you writing logs then
building and deploying and then again
getting the logs reviewing them and so
we're going to keep doing this for every
bug just this one to start with but
wouldn't be great if we had a tool
though that we could where we could see
this happening while it's running and
then Q we're going to talk about lauda
bugger like your excellent and I said
this was going to come up again we could
talk about debugger I mean I could go
through more slides but why don't we
just show them the
in action okay I could write a cover the
flights later it's a good idea now here
again we have another link and this will
take us to what we saw before and this
time we'll stay in debugger for a little
longer now what's happening here we see
our source that's loaded here and just
to let you know the debugger has
different options for getting access to
source code in this case we're using our
cloud source repository you've got the
source code loaded here so it's it knows
by kind of module inversion and you know
kind of what's in by the deployment
what's running here it can also read
code from local local source I'm in this
case it doesn't actually send any of the
source to Google at all it just loads
the source in the browser session and
gets the information it needs to set
these snapshots here in fact I think we
can even do that without any without
yeah you I mean let's assume that if you
don't have access to source code at all
you can just give in give it a file name
and a line number and we'll still take a
snapshot and that and when you take a
snapshot as we did what I was doing here
is that it's just hitting the same
reproving the same error on my laptop
here and we got a snapshot this is
happening in production it is not
impacting any of the users so we are
basically we're adding minimal overhead
to your application again we're thinking
about single-agent milliseconds of
microseconds it doesn't even matter
whether your application is running on
one instance or a hundred thousand
instances we will still be able to
capture a snapshot and capture the
entire application stage no matter which
instance it heads and then bring it back
yeah and that's important when we think
about debuggers we often think about
setting a break point and then halting
execution of the code and maybe playing
around with the machine state setting
registers backing up the code pointer
running it again and that's great in
some situations when we have a dedicated
machine where we can reproduce these
problems often with cloud apps
you don't have that kind of flexibility
some of the problems that we see maybe
due to maybe resource limitations or
lots of user traffic we may not easily
be able to reproduce these problems when
they happen in distributed apps this way
so what a snapshot will let us do is
capture a view of the Machine state on
whatever machine that the snapshots
taken from and it'll save it away in a
session for us to look at any time and
it won't interfere with the operation as
we just mentioned so astronauts said
while we were doing that he actually hit
the app again I see a big red box there
and we took the snapshot you may have
noticed it said waiting for snapshot and
we executed this code so now I'm going
to rearrange the screen a little bit so
we can get a little better view on this
I guess I should be able to do that okay
well I'll just scroll through these guys
as we can see we've got local variables
here you can see you've got this is a an
instance method so we have this pointer
and then we have our request in response
parameters there that are passed in and
then we have some local variables down
here we have vote LOL because we press
the LOL button to make this thing
explode we have current null it's
probably kind of what we're interested
in here so we're going to take a look at
the code and see what we're doing now
thinking back on this I remember what I
did I think as we improve upon this
sentence generator we're going to keep
track of the quality of the sentences
that it produces so we have these voting
buttons and eventually you're gonna
we're going to probably store these in
some kind of system where we can run
some analytics on them we can record
information maybe about how long it took
a user before they click the button and
which options they chose for which
sentences but for now since I was asked
to do this and short notice I just kind
of take them and stick him into a map
just just to have something just get
some code out the door
so it looks like i am taking out of my
vote counts map I'm retrieving a vote
with key vote there and I'm taking the
current integer a box integer that we
have i'm adding 1 to it and I'm writing
it back into our map I can see right
away if vote is not in the map then
current will be no and why is about not
in the map i click the LOL button and
i'm going to look up here at where i
initialize my map and i can see I
someone maybe me you got a little
excited here and i put LOL in caps and
when i look at what we have here you see
that LOL is lowercase now this is
terrible code it's not robust we should
never do anything like this ever but we
did and we suffer the consequences but
debugger helped us find the problem so
that's right i mean if the production
debugger were the way stackdriver
debugger works it just completely
revolutionizes in my opinion how you
would debug code in production you can
capture application states study your
behavior of your code and all of this
without ever having to pause interrupt
your application and and and all of this
data is available in New York of time we
also have the ability to share the
session oh that's right I don't have
anyone to share it with but I can share
it with myself so i'll just copy the
link here and i will put this into a new
tab now we'll run this you can see we've
got the same session run that you have
our snapshot there in the same line on
the same the same file and we've got
kind of the same state the same stack
trace the same oh there we go this is
what I was trying to do before so you
the same variables so that's right i
mean the ability for you to share your
debugging sessions or any of your
diagnosis sessions across any of these
tools is as easy as a copy and a paste
and if the person receiving it
access to those resources you can just
they'll just be able to see that exact
same data and in this case you can see
the entire all the variables you can see
the stack you can see everything it's
also it makes it really easy for
engineers to collaborate which I which
often happens in order to troubleshoot
your app that's right alright so looks
like you can fix that bug later should
we just go back to the slides and
so I actually went through all of these
I think we went through all of these so
I think the slides are a little bit
redundant and you can just go to this is
again redundant I think the only thing
I'll call out here is we have many
source code options I think Eric talked
about it we've got a local and cloud
repo and you can upload your code and
when you do upload your code that code
is stored and by gcp and it's available
for that entire debugging session so
when you do a share you close your
browser come back later and somebody
else or you shared it to somebody else
that code is available for you you can
do with no source at all just give a
file name and the line number and that's
it again a very it's like a five-mile
view of how debugger works we've got
we've got a debugger service we've got
debugger agents and we've got an agent
controller when you weren't set up a
snapshot your debugger service
coordinates with the debugger agent
takes a snapshot sends it back and you
see what and you basically see what what
we just demoed so just to summarize when
you're diagnosing your application
hopefully it's pretty clear for everyone
that if you're dealing with performance
issues trace should be one of the first
destinations to understand what is
happening within your application and to
be able to slice and dice the trace data
so that you can actually find the root
cause and find the bottlenecks error
reporting as I've emphasized pin it if
you if you if you if you got an
application running in gcp go ahead and
pin the error reporting page and that's
something that is going to be
tremendously useful our customers whom
we have already released it to honor on
a private beta have come back with
phenomenal feedback the dot telling us
how incredibly valuable it is
and and debug I think this is one of
those things where it's one of the best
tools that I abuse personally in terms
of stepping through the behavior of your
code and understanding what is happening
within your application without really
interrupting your normal operations as
I've already talked about before all of
this stuff works natively in a
distributed environment we can scale
very comfortably we can scale from one
instance your applications running in
one instance 20 many of our customers
run their application the hundreds of
thousands of instances and so we can
capture all this data seamlessly we
another aspect of scale to think about
is if they take trace for example we
have about a billion trace is
approximately a billion traces coming
into a system every day and every one of
the stresses is analyzed to look for
different call patterns suboptimal color
patterns and we surface that we this is
tightly integrated into develop over
close and of course our team as you saw
it is actually shipping features as we
talk here so you can see you can you'll
start seeing length show up between logs
to traces and debugger you there's
already a bunch of integrations that has
happened where you can access all this
data of this tool directly from your
dashboards whether it's applet but it's
your App Engine dashboard or whether
it's your stackdriver dashboard incident
management is there's integrations for
all these tools within your incident
management systems and and I can't
highlight enough about the extensibility
here all these tools are publicly
available we are ap is as well and and
so that lets you incorporate it within
your own systems so that you can let's
say if you wanted to add your own custom
spans where you wanted to measure your
own custom workflows and you want to
still leverage all the trace analytics
that we have then you can do that and of
course the best part of it is it's all
free we're not charging anything for
this
it is available out of the box but
you're not sure I'd it's not just about
the cost it's about the value you got it
thanks thank you very much folks
you